お願いします と あの怒りというテーマについて
あの二回目の講演でございますが
で 今日はいくらか このどのようにすれば我々の怒りという感情が収まるかという説明ですか
まああの たくさん方法ありますから
まああまりにもありすぎて
どう言えばいいかわからないほどたくさんありますけど
まあ適当にいくらか方法を説明します
で 怒りということは まあなくす一番簡単な方法があるんです
もう完全になくす簡単な方法があります
それはまあ怒らないことなんです
ただ 本当はそれだけのことなんですね
怒らなきゃ そういうことなのに
まあ私はわからないのは
なんでこの怒りはどのようにすればなくなりますかという
この方法を考えるんですかと
そこに自分にはお分かりになると思いますよ
怒らなきゃいいのに 怒らない方法を教えてくださいとまた言うんですね
で そこに私は何を言いたいんですかというと
私は勝手に怒りますよと
好きに怒りたい放題 思い存分
でも怒りは嫌だから何か方法を教えてくださいと
それはもうそんな甘くはないんだからね
ですから 結局は方法はないんですよ
怒らなきゃそれだけのことで
ですから 結局我々何を理解するべきかというと
なぜ怒るかということなんです
別に怒りをなくす方法じゃないんです
なぜ怒るかということが大事であって
怒りをなくす方法は別に方法はないんだからね
怒らなきゃいいんです
何者にも ですから 我々はなぜ怒るかというと
我々には怒る えーと 何と言いますか
言い訳があるんですね
こういうことで怒ったんですか
こういうことで怒ったんです
その言い訳一つ一つ分析してみると
またそれも自分の我がままで
好き勝手で もう自分がいろんなことを判断して怒っているということが分かります
ですから この最初にも言ったように
怒らなきゃいいのに 別に方法はなぜ聞くかと
で そこに矛盾がありますね
私たちはまあ怒りたくて怒りたくてしょうがないんです
で またどこかで心の中で
まあ怒らない方がいいんじゃないかなとまた思ったりする
そこにも矛盾があって
まあ怒らない方法を考えたりはするんですね
で 怒りが生まれない方法ですから
この なぜ怒るかということは
この前の講演でまあ ichi ichi 説明しましたからね
まあえーと そんなに今日は説明する必要はないんです
で 人間というのはいつでも自分が正しいと思っているんじゃないんですか？私が正しい
それで怒るんです 相手が正しくない
間違っている 相手が正しいと思ったら
あまり怒るってことはあまりないんです
それを覚えておいてください
私は完全に正しい 完全だ
完璧だ で で 相手方が悪いんだと
で それで怒る それから相手に対してじゃなくて
自分に怒る場合もありますよ
その時も同じことなんですね
例えば何か仕事をしようとする
うまくいかない それですごく自分に怒ってしまうんですね
例えば自分が病気になったと
がんになったと聞いたら随分怒るんです
自分に対して なんで私ががんになったんですかと
なんでこの仕事うまくいかないんですかと
なんで今日の料理は失敗しましたかと
そういうふうに自分に怒る場合もありますね
それ 他人に怒る場合は
私が正しくて相手相手方が間違っているという立場で怒りますけど
自分に怒る場合は その時も同じなんです
私が完璧なのに なんで料理が失敗したんですかと
ああ 嫌だと 私には完璧に仕事をできるのに
なんでこれなかなかうまくいかないかと
ということで怒るんです
ですから この私は完璧だ
正しいんだという考え方はいかがでしょうかと
そこで 本当に人間との矛盾というのは
もし私がどなたから聞いたら
本当にそちらの方が大変完璧な人ですかと
全く正しい方 正しいと自分が思っていますか？と言えば
いいえ とんでもない 私は全然そうは思ってないんだと
とは言うんです それでああそう
じゃああんたはただのバカですねと
もし私が次に言ったら
すぐ怒るんですね ですから
そこによく矛盾がありまして
ある心のところで いわゆる表向で
建前として言うんです
私は まあダメだ ダメな人間だ
あだこだとか 心の中で絶対そうじゃないんだと
私こそ唯一で正しいんだと
他の連中が方々はもう全く無茶苦茶で間違ってるんだという同体で考えているんですね
ですから そこで人間は
なんでそう思うんですかね
ですから ほんのわずか客観的な知識知恵あれば
私は正しいと思わないんです
私は正しいと言えないんだと
私も不完全だと 間違いだらけだと
それは頭心に入っちゃうと
もうその人は二度と怒りませんよ
例えば 母親が子供に何か怒ったりする
先生が生徒に怒ったりするとか
女子が部下に怒ったりするとかね
客観的に見たところで
女子やら子供やら何か間違ってることはしているかもしれません
そこで怒って喋ると その時も我々
私たちの怒りを正当化する
あなたは間違っていることをやったんだから
で 間違っていることをやったならば
それは説明して 二度とこういうことをしてはいけないとニコニコと言えばいいのに
なんで怒るんですかと
それは間違っているよ
こういうことで間違っているとニコニコと言えばいいのに
その時は随分怒っちゃうんですね
その時まで同じ概念なんですね
自分はもう正しいんだと
自分の言葉も正しいんだと
自分の考え方は正しいんだと
そこで怒るんです ですから
2番目の方法っていうのは
私は完全だと思っている
このとんでもない このアホらしい考え方を捨てた方がいいんじゃないんですか
ちょっと考えてみてください
もう完成になるはずがないし
我々みんな人間というのは知識人であるならば
物事を判断できる人であるならば
私は正しいかどうか 正しいかどうかではなくて
もう決して正しくはないんだと
今こういうことを言うんだけど
それもやっぱりガタガタの意見だよと
言葉も完璧じゃないし
自分使っている単語も完璧じゃないし
もう何一つも完璧にできないし
ですから たとえ子供が生徒が部下が間違いを起こしても
自分の喋り方が間違っているかもしれません
そうするとどっちでも間違いを起こしているんだから
ですから この自分が正しいと思う考え方を
非合理的で非真実で嘘でありえないことで
このありえないことを頭で徹底的に信じている自分ほど大馬鹿も世の中にないんだと
はっきりと理解したところで
もう怒らなくなっちゃうんです
それ 2番目の 私たちの心の中で
私たちは正しいと思っていることを間違っていると
正しいのはあるはずがないんだと
で 私たちの我々はこの世の中で
人間の中で お釈迦様ほど完璧な人間は現れませんと
テーラワーダ仏教で我々はそういうふうに信じているんです
皆様は信じても信じなくても
それは別に私に関係ないんだけど
私たちはそういうふうに信じているし
もうどういうふうな研究してみたっても
やっぱりお釈迦様の方が優れていると見えちゃうんですね
そしてお釈迦様のお経なんか見ると
お釈迦様は随分人と喋ると
どのように言葉を使った方がいいかと
そういうところはものすごく気をつけていたんですね
言葉の使い方 ですから
いい加減な言葉を使わないで
ものすごい丁寧に 丁寧と言ったってちょっとおかしいかもしれませんけど
ものすごい真剣に言葉を選んで話していたんですね
それでも言葉は言葉だから
言葉自体不完全だから
誤解を招いたことはあるんです
ある人に一言二言二言葉であなたの教えを説明してくださいと言われたら
お釈迦様はいわかりましたと
ちょっと一行で三つ四つぐらいの言葉で自分の教えを教えちゃう
わかるわけないですよね
相手が それで相手がそれに腹が立って
なんだわけのわからないことを言うんですかと
で 帰っちゃう それでお釈迦様は怒りません
普通のだったら あなたでしょうに
短く説明してくれと言ったのは
と怒ってもいいんだけど
お釈迦様はそういう場合は怒りません
そこでお釈迦様は自分の比丘たちの前で
こういう人が来て こういう質問したところで
私はこういうふうに答えたんだと
その人はベロを出して帰っていったんだと
分からなくて 何のことなく説明するんですね
そこでお坊さんたちがそのお釈迦様がおっしゃったことはどういう意味がありますか？説明してくださいと頼むときは
そういう部分を延々と説明してあげるんです
深い哲学ですから そういうそういういろんなストーリーの中で見えるのは
たとえお釈迦様にさえ
完璧に完全に喋るということはいつでもできるわけないんです
そこでお釈迦様はそれを知っていて
それは当たり前で この人を怒るのは
この人ベロを出して私をからかって帰るのは
別に何も思わないんです
私はこんなにちゃんと言っているのに
なんであんた理解しないんですかというふうに怒りません
母親っていうのは あなたに何回聞いたらわかりますか？どころでしょうに
何かやってはいけないと
言うは言うは言うは それでも子供は聞いてくれない
それであんたに何回言ったらそれ理解わかりますかと
もしかすると何回言ってもわからないかもしれませんし
それは自分に言っている言葉が正しくないかもしれませんし
ですから正しくないかもしれませんではなくて
正しくはないんです 不完全なんです
我々は精一杯やっているだけのことで
それはうまくいくかいかないかわからないんですね
うまくいってほしいと思う
その完全な無知な概念を捨てちゃえばいいんです
例えば夫婦円満にしようと
奥さんがもうものすごい精一杯頑張っちゃうんだと
それは精一杯頑張ることはわかりますけど
でもそのやり方は世界一絶対的な正しいやり方と
そう限ってはないんです
例えば あまりにも相手のことを心配して面倒見ちゃうと
あまり面倒見すぎて嫌われる可能性もあるし
奥さんがやっぱり男性っていうのは優しい人には惹かれますよ
ですから 私はとことんこの男に優しくしてあげようとしたところで
それにも向こう側が気持ち悪がるかもしれませんし
そこはもう誰もわかったもんじゃないんです
なぜかというと それどっちにも完全じゃないんです
じゃあ 例えば 私はずっと旦那のことを随分親切に優しく面倒見てあげたんだと
それなのにその人はこういうふうな生活を今しているんだと言われた時は
もしこう聞けば あなたには自信がありますか？あなたは完璧に完全に自分のことをやったんですかと
自分で自分のするべき分を
その自分の心で決めそうではないということも見えてくる可能性ありますよ
そうすると まあ精一杯頑張りましたということは別に私は認めていますけどね
精一杯は頑張りました
結果はあまり自分の希望通りにはいってない
でも悔しくはないんだと
なぜならば精一杯頑張ったんだから
ですから 精一杯努力するのは別に悪いことじゃない
いいことなんですね それに完全な結果を求めるのは
人間のとんでもない とてつもない無知なところなんです
ですから 自分が完全ではなくて
他人からも決して完全な結果を求めない方が
我々には落ち着いてこの世の中で生きていられる秘密なんです
完全じゃないんだと 私も他人も誰でも
何一つも完璧にうまくするっていうことはもうありえないんだと
だからって中途半端でいい加減で物事をしちゃうと
それは良くないっていうことは当たり前のことで
一応精一杯はしますが
結果はまあそれは分かりませんという状態というふうな知識的な行動な生き方に入れ替えちゃうと
もう怒りには現れる余地がないんです
ですから 怒るたびに その人は自分が完全だ完璧だと思っていることで
ひどい目に遭うだけなんです
それで自分が完璧だと思うのはすごいバカバカらしいでしょう
ものすごい無知な考え方なんですね
どう見ても それ無知な考え方で
ですから怒るでしょう
それでもう一つわかりますよ
怒る人ほどこの世の中で頭の悪い人はいないんだと
そういうのは私は真剣に言ってますよ
冗談ではなくて 怒る人は本当にもうこの世の中でも恥ずかしいほど頭が悪いんです
ですから 怒る人はもうもう何て言いますか
すっごい徹底した無知な人だと
覚えておいてください
ですから 自分たちが普通の知識的な能力ある才能ある人間になりたいか
まあ動物以下の無知な愚痴な人間になりたいかということで
怒るか怒らないかということは決められます
怒りたび怒るたびに 我々は我々の無知そのものを刺激するんです
無明無知 それを刺激してどんどんバカになるんです
怒れば怒るほど もう完全にもうもう人間でも動物でもないんです
ですから 怒らないために
こういう風に自分に言ってください
怒るのはバカだよと 真剣に自分に言わなくちゃいけないんです
私は合理的でなく完全なバカだから
何も理解しない 何も理解できない
無知な人だから怒っているんだと
それでこの心の感情っていうのは
もう波をいつでも波で回してるんですね
であの 自分たちの生活を見ると
自分たちが本当に頭が冴えて
すごい頭が冴えて しっかりと物事を判断して把握して行動すると怒らないでしょ
例えば子供が何か悪いことをしたとわかっても
やっぱり状況をちゃんと把握している
どう言えばいいかもよくわかっている
なぜそうなったかと その時はあまり怒らないんですね
がっかりもしない 怒りもしない
落ち着く 自分の頭が冴えて仕事をしている時
全然怒らないんですね
ということは 知恵が働いていると怒らないということなんです
怒る時 自分の心を見てください
その時能力もないし 明るさもないし
判断もできないし ですから
瞬時にこの完全たる最低の無知な人間になっちゃうんです
そこでそれは回数重なると心の法則というものがあるんです
心の法則っていうのは
何か繰り返しちゃうと
その通りになってしまうんです
で なんでこの世の中ね
皆様知ってるんでしょ？マインドコントロールだらけで
これはいいわ これはいいわ
これと何回も繰り返しちゃうと
みんなそれはいいんだと
もうすぐ決めつけて終わっちゃうでしょうに
この食べ物美味しいんだ
美味しいんだと言っちゃうと
それ食べたら美味しく感じちゃうし
だからこのずっと世の中
人間っていうのは互いに暗示かけ合ったりして
マインドコントロールし合ったりして
まあとんでもない世界作ってますけど
そこにも何を使っているかというと
この心っていうのは同じことを繰り返して繰り返して言っちゃうと
そのようになってしまうんです
ですから このフリークエンシー
この回数 で この怒る回数が回数大きくなればなるほど
その人が怒りの人間になってしまうんです
それは恐ろしい損なんですよ
なぜならば 怒りの人間になったっていうことは
もう人間じゃないんです
ただの肉の塊が動いている
肉の塊とはお化けと同じ
もう怖いもんでしょうに
みんな見たいんですかね？夜一人でいると
なんかお化けが出る 目が一つないし
口から血が出たりとかね
剥がれむそといてたりとか
恐ろしい顔のお化けなんか出たらもう怖いでしょうね
だからこの我々の目の前でもう肉の塊が動いたり
歩いたり 喋ったりしているんだから
これ怖いんですよ ですから
怒りの人間になるということは
もう人間を捨てたことになるんです
その人に何の成長も 何の発展もない
レベル的に言えば 次元的に言えば動物よりは随分下なんです
なんでそう言いますかと
動物っていうのはこの共同生活
互いの気持ちをいつでも計算しようということはずっとやっているんです
相手の気持ちをいつでももう鋭く敏感に感じて感じていないと
動物の世界では生きていられない
わがままではダメなんです
動物も怒るんだけど それはまあまた違うことで次元で怒りますけど
例えば犬同士でも なぜ犬が怒るかというと
その犬の道徳を破ったら怒るんであって
そうでないと怒らないんですね
猿の世界でも同じで 決まり破っちゃったら殺されるぐらい殴られて
もう噛まれて いろんなひどい目に遭いますよ
殺しはしませんだけど
もう結局怪我しちゃったら死んでしまう可能性もあります
ですから 自分の命に関係あるんだから
動物はいつでもこのこの共同生活ですか
この互いに気をつけて
互いの気持ちをよく理解して生活しようとする
ですから その次元からも落ちているんだから
怒る人が だから 前も言ったように
わかりやすいよ 怒らない方がいいんです
方法を探すんじゃなくて
怒らない方がいいんです
怒るということは ものすごいもう恐ろしく
自分が無知のもう生命も人間性をもう捨てたことになるんだと
たとえ瞬間でも その瞬間でもう人間を捨てたことになるんです
お化けみたいに動く肉の塊だけになってしまったんです
植物人間みたいになってしまって
ですから 例えば人を殺すは
人をぶん殴るは 批判するは
ありとあらゆる恐ろしいこと
この世の中で起こるのは
その人が怒っている時でしょうね
ものすごく怒って人を殺してるでしょうに
ものすごく怒って人を侮辱したり批判したりするでしょうに
すごく怒って国と国が戦ったり
戦争したりしてるんじゃないんですか？ですから
私は嘘をついているわけじゃないんです
怒ってる時は その人はただのお化けも化け物
化け物なんです 鬼なんです
人間じゃないんです 皆さんはよくたまに言うでしょ
あの人怒ったらもう鬼ですよ
人間じゃないんですよ
そういうことは一般的に我々の社会でも言ってることだから
ですから この回数重ねて怒ってはいけないんです
回数重ねると重ねるほど
それほど怖いものはないんです
ですから 怒ることはものすごい恐ろしいことだと
たとえわずかでも 自分の頭に言ってあげてください
で 怒ったらすぐ自分がそういうずっとどん底に
生命の次元でどん底に落ちたと
そちらにいてはいけないんだと
まだざっと人間の次元に戻ってこなくちゃいけないんです
それはもういわゆる 3番目の方法
怒るのはもう最低な無知な人であるということを
もう人間性捨てることやと
と理解しておいてください
怒る瞬間で 自分には何も理解も合理性も客観性も何もないんだと
そう見ると怒らなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 怒りが生まれる方法を解釈すると
怒らないことは怒らない方法はそこにあるんです
一応 3番目の方法としては
そういうふうにこの知恵のことを考えて
無知にはなりたくはないんだと
それでまた まず一般的な日常生活の中で使ういろいろいくつかの方法を説明してあげて
それから仏教の世界のことも
時間ある限りちょっと説明します
で 怒らないために何か工夫ないかと
ちょっとした工夫があるんです
よく笑ってください 我々は忘れた
この笑うこと また生き返してあげてください
心で なんで人間笑わないかと
わからないんですね 笑って生活してもいいのに
ですから心に決めれば
私は今からよく笑う人間になりますと
恥ずかしがらないで 堂々と笑うんだと
声出してでも笑うんだと
そこでも実践してみると
笑いことと怒りは正反対の性格だから
何があろうとも笑いますよと決めたら
もう理解は簡単ですけど
方法は少々難しいかもしれませんだけどね
笑っちゃえばいいんです
怒っても笑っちゃえばいいんです
それで怒りが消えちゃうんです
よく笑うこと いつでも笑うこと
この何か日本でこの笑う
何て言いますか 治療法もありますね
がん治療を一つ通して
いっぱい人を笑わせて
患者さんをね 笑わせてあげる
そうするとこの免疫システムが活性化して
細胞悪い細胞をなくしてくれるということで
かなり体にはいいし 明るくなるし
怒るのはものすごい無知な時起こるんだけど
正しい笑いが生まれる時は
わずかに知識が働いてるんですね
例えば簡単に言えば なんで笑っちゃう
おかしいんだからって言うでしょ
おかしくておかしくて
もう笑っちゃったんだと
それおかしいということは
普通の法則から見ればおかしいんだから
自分がそのおかしさに笑ってるんですよ
ですから 笑う瞬間で無知ではないんです
バカではないんです アホじゃないんです
怒る時はもうそうじゃなくて
正反対なんです 何もわからわからない
そう怒ってしまう ですから
怒る代わりに笑っちゃうと
無知の代わりに知恵が知識が必要なんです
で皆様 このいろんなこの文学ありますね
人を笑うためのいろんなね
作文やら歌やら もういろんな漫才やらいろんなものあるんですね
そういうのはこの もうちょっと客観的に見てみてください
その漫才師が言ってるストーリーとか
笑わないで その場合はよく観察してみてください
何であんな話を聞いて人が笑いますかというと
そこにそういうストーリーを作った人々が
この人間の生き方 いろんなことをちゃんと勉強して理解して
それをおかしくするんです
ただバカみたいに笑い笑っているわけじゃないんです
人を笑わせるのは大変な仕事なんです
かなり知恵 知識必要なんです
理解能力 そこで普通だったら人はこういう時
こういう時 こういうことをするんだと
それでストーリー作っちゃう作っちゃうんです
こういう場合 こういう場合
こういうふうにするのは正しいのに
こういうふうにしてしまったと
昨日の勉強会でも言ったんだけど
漫画のクレヨンしんちゃんですか
そこはあの この漫画のキャラクターがいつでももうとんでもないことを言う
反対のことばっかり言うんですね
それで面白いんですね
あの漫画は 言ってるメッセージも
私にも気に入ってるんです
うちにこの小学生かな
玄関から入るとただいまじゃなくてお帰りなさいって言うんです
それでお母さんがお帰りなさい
ただいまでしょうと と怒ると
それであの子はやれやれ
女っていうのはなかなか
だから全部おかしいでしょうに
ですから なんでそこに笑いますかというと
常識なやり方っていうものはそこにあって
そこに反対のことをやらせるとそこに笑うという働きが生まれるんでしょうし
ですから 笑う瞬間で我々の頭が冴えているんです
いくらかの事実見えてるんです
だから笑うんです そこで一生懸命冗談を言ってるのに笑わない人がいるでしょ
あれなんですか？全然理解してないんですね
ですから 笑わない場合はもうまたもうもう頭もうパンク
理解してないんです 例えば冗談も通じない人だと
我々人のことたまに言うでしょ
冗談も通じない人だと我々は人を批判すると
我々その人に対してどんな態度をとってますか？この人
冗談も通じないバカではないかということじゃないんですか？冗談さえ通じないんだと
もう呆れ呆れたもんだと
それぐらいバカだと ということは
笑うことと一緒に理解というものが働いているんです
そうでないと そうでないと
このヒューマンというものは生まれません
ですから笑ってください
よく それは幸福でもあるし
なんとか笑うところにね
まあ幸福が来るという話がありますからね
健康的にもなるし 免疫作用がすごい活性化するし
体は健康になるは 顔色が美しくなるは
お化粧のお金がそこでもうかるは
すごい美しくなるんです
笑う人っていうのはみんなに愛されますから
だからこれ いろんな面でもう結構幸福になりますよ
無駄なお金使わなくても済みますからね
お化粧やらおしゃれやら
そういうものはかなりお金かかっちゃうでしょうね
そういうお金貯まって他のことできるし
ですから この心の中でもう怒ってる人がね
結局あの宝石やらもったいないでしょう
つけたっても気持ち悪いんだから
誰にも近寄れないんだから
ただお金の無駄遣いだけでしょう
ですから この笑うと全部もう健康も社会のね
人間関係ももうなんだかんだうまい方向へ変えてしまう
確実に幸福になる 幸福だから笑うんじゃなくて
笑って幸福になってくださいということ
そこでこの笑うことに対してから少々注意しなくちゃいけないことがあるんです
幸福だから笑うとちょっと危ないんです
それは無知なんです どこかに落とし穴あるんです
それで私は幸福が全部揃ってるんだ
お金もあるんだ ああだこうだとか
あまりにも満足して納得いって笑ってるんだと
ひどい目に遭うんです
その人が そういう世界ないんだから
私は満足だ 全部完璧になってるんだとかね
問題はないんだと 子供は問題なしと
旦那は奥さんは問題なしと
会社は問題なしとかね
冗談じゃないんです 私は幸せだとか生きていてよかったとか
その笑い方はものすごい無知な笑い方なんです
2つあるんです 知恵の笑い方と無知な人の怠け者の笑い方
ですから 幸福だから笑う人が危ない
気をつけた方がいい それはまあ
何て言いますか 怠けにつなげちゃうし
えっと 仏教用語で言えば放逸ですか
放逸につなげてしまうんですね
放逸って  しっかりしないという意味なんですね
そういう意味でしたっけ
わかりませんが ですから
笑い方のちょっとした 2つあるんです
で ただ あのバカみたく無知な
無知で笑うということではなくて
本当の一つの もうちょっと考えて物事に笑うという知識的なレベルで笑うことなんです
でもう一つ注意してほしいのは
この笑うんだからといって
その笑うということにふけてはいけないんです
楽しくて楽しくて笑って笑って
そればっかりやって もう全部仕事を忘れてしまったと
そういうのは正しい笑い方じゃないんです
それはもうマヤカと同じく
何か面白いものに惹かれてるだけなんですよ
それでもない 幸福だから笑うことでもない
その二つを置いておいて
ニコニコと笑うと 例えばこのバカな人との
例えば笑いたくて笑いたくて
あっちこっちこのもう漫才のやってるところやら
いろんな面白いところを探し探して行ったりして
そこで笑って家に帰るとか
そういう人は家に帰ったら笑えないんだからそこに行くんです
ですから その笑い方は正しくはない
私が言う笑い方は 家にいたっても外いたっても笑えると
仕事がうまくいっても
仕事は失敗しても笑えるんだと
ですから わざわざ笑うためにどこかへ行く必要はない
その笑い方ですから それはどのように訓練するかというと
まあすぐ笑えばそれだけのことで
それは身につくんです
すぐ笑えば まあすぐ笑えようと思っても笑えないかもしれませんでしょ
それで正直な人がそれでも笑わなくちゃいけないと思って
強引に笑っちゃうんですよ
強引に笑ってみると どんどん自分でこの
そのその時の何かおかしいことを見つけることできるんです
いわゆる知恵が咲いてくるんです
だから  24時間面白くて楽しく生活する人が
何を見てもなんか面白いこと見つかっちゃうんです
何か面白いことを見つかっちゃうんです
大体子供を見ると 子供はこのどこにいても 1分経たないうちに何か遊ぶこと見つかるでしょうに
何をあげても構いません
どこに連れて行っても構いません
そこでちょっと 1分ぐらいじーっと待っていると
子供は遊び始めちゃうんです
そこで結構 その子供には遊ぶ道具やらもの
全部あるんですね 小さい時だけなんです
それは で 小さな子供を笑わせることはすごい簡単なんです
いないいないばあと言ったって笑っちゃいますから
だから あれ なんで子供笑う？子供笑ってわかってないと思いますけどね
でもその時は子供わかるのは
まあまあ 母親が楽しがっているんだからね
自分も楽しい それだけのことで
かもしれませんだけど
ですからこの そういう風に私たちもこの何があろうと笑いますよと決めたら
その笑うためのこの何かおかしいことっていうのは見つかるんですよ
それで不思議なこと すべての現象はおかしいんです
何かあるんですよ 変なところは
変なところないものは何もないんです
いわゆる世の中で完全なもの何もないんだから
ですから 本当に笑いたければ何でもいいんです
だから残念ながら それを私は実証的に見せてあげるしか方法ないんだけどね
たまに一緒にいる人々にちょっと時間でもそれを教えとはするんだけど
全く大失敗 やっぱり理解しないんですね
だからこちら まあこの人は自分一人で笑いますよってことで
一人で笑ってますけど
で どんなものの中でもすごい面白いこと見つかるんですよ
何一つも完全じゃないという立場で私は見ているんだから
例えば雨が降って傘をさして
行って電車に乗ったと
傘をたたむと傘の先何かありますね
なんて言いますか この
あの 一番あの手で取るところにありますね
丸く丸くして それは合理的に言えば完璧に丸くなければいけませんだけど
見てください そうじゃないんです
上を下上下いろいろギザギザとか
1本わずかに出ていたりとかね
それで上から何か下へ差して
それで止まってもらうでしょ
それはきちんと落ちた方が合理的に正しいんだけど
やっぱりそうでもないんでしょうね
だからそれみたいな なるほど
これこちらで曲がっているんだとか
これはちょっと飛んでるんだとかね
見たってもそこにちょっとした
[笑い]面白いこと出てくる
私は大体子供やることばっかりやってますけど
傘から水が垂れるでしょうに
水が垂れてずっと流れていくんで
僕はどこに行くんですか？とか
電車がブレーキかけたらどこに行くんですか？とか
もう動く どこ どこら辺に行くかどうか
だからどこにも行けない場合は
いろいろ形で水が垂れたり
いろんなことしたりとか
もう何もわからないんだけど
そういうことをいつでもやってるんです
だからもう本当にこのお腹が痛くなるほど笑おうと思ったら
それでも笑えるんですよ
でもそうはしませんだけど
でも何があろうとも 誰にも言わないんだけど
心の中ではそれをからかってるんです
ですから ほんのちょっと知恵使えば
どんなものの中でも この笑うということは
傘の例なんですけど 傘をたたんで
それから何かバンドでつけるようになるでしょ
あるでしょうね そこで傘を丁寧に畳んでみてください
あのバンドは長すぎなんです
きちんとしっかりと丁寧に畳んだら
あのバンドは長すぎ なんで長すぎかと考えたことがあります？あれはみんな落ち着きないんだから
慌て者だから バカもんだから
もうサササッと畳もうとするんです
だからそれやりながら他のこと考えてるんだから
だからもう丁寧にあれ巻いたらもう長いし
いい加減巻いたらちょうどぴったしなんです
そして僕は なるほど これいい加減なアホな連中のために作っている傘だと
真面目にそれすごく畳んじゃうと
これ長すぎて これハサミで切ってやろうかなと思うぐらい
ですから そういうもう何のことないところで
私はそういうことを言ったんです
それ何でもいいんで 私に例出してください
僕は見せますよ こういうところでこういうことありますと
ですから 笑おうと思っちゃえば
もう何でもいいんです
何でもいいんです そういうことで
我々には怒りを打ち消すことはできるんです
笑うことによって それによってなぜできます？それ科学的な法則なんですよ
笑うためには知恵を使わなくちゃいけない
すごい合理的にちゃんとこのシステムを理解してないと笑えないんですよ
ということは 笑うと知恵が生じてくる
知恵ある人は怒らないんです
怒るのはもうバカ バカもんだから
無知だから怒るんですから
そういうシステムです
で 次の方法なんですが
方法と言ったっても こういう
こういう風に頭で考えておいた方がいいということなんですけど
私は前の講演会で言ったんです
人間というのはものすごいエゴイストで
エゴさえ捨てればすべては解決するんだと
ここに私というものはいるわけじゃないんだと
そこでエゴイストだから
エゴを持ってるんだから
自我を持ってるんだから
もう他人がいるということを仮定して
他人を敵に回しちゃって
まあ怒るしかないんですね
敵ばっかりだから この世の中敵に回しているのは
我々はこのエゴを作っているんだからなんですね
ここに私がいるんだ 私は何々さんだ
私は会社の何々部長だ
課長だとか 私は女性だ
男性だとかね そういう私に対するいろんな概念使ってるんだから
そういう概念壊れると怒るんです
たまにこの完全な頭の悪い男の人々を言うんですね
もう で それを聞くと私もすごい怒りますけどね
まあ女性にお茶入れてくださいと
女性が忙しいとかなんとかって
もうなんとかちょっと嫌な反応しちゃったら
あんた女だろ？と言うんですね
女はお茶入れるの当たり前だと
あれを聞くと こいつは男で生まれて男として恥ずかしいなとと思いますけどね
できれば矯正でもしてあげたいぐらいなんですけど
そこで互いに怒りますけど
そういう女だからこういうことをしなくちゃいけないと
ずいぶんエゴで考えているんですね
それで丁寧に自分が命令したことをやってくれないと怒るんです
それは無知なエゴから生まれる無知そのものなんです
誰が決めたんですか？そんなことは
例えば私は上司だから部下は言うこと聞くのは当たり前だと
誰が決めたんです？そんなことは
それただのエゴなんですよ
部下でも上司がバカだったら
部下が上司言うこと聞いちゃったらひどい目遭うでしょうに
だから正しいことを実行するんであって
部下だからと課長だからと
社長だからと ああだこうだとか
家の主人だからといって
そんなことないでしょうに
仏教の世界では たとえうちの子供でも正しいことを言うならば
それはみんなで実行して認めるべきであって
お前子供のくせにくせで癖に生意気ではないかというのは
もうその人こそ間違っているし
無知であるし そういう人はそういうことで怒りを他人も起こしてしまっちゃうし
自分も怒るし ですから
エゴは一番大きな問題で
エゴにいろんなこのゴミがつけるんですよ
エゴというものが作ったところで
私は男だ 若者だ 中年だ
老人だとか 私は課長だ
社長だ 部長だとか 私はああだこうだとか
ありとあらゆるこの汚れがついちゃう
その一つ一つ汚れに外から攻撃されると
もう怒ってしまう 例えば自分が男だと思ったところで
誰かが男をバカにしちゃったらもう怒るんです
私は女だと思っている人に
人の前で女をバカにしちゃったら
その人は怒ってしまうんです
だから私は何々だと思っていたところで問題あるんであって
そうでないとそこに問題ないんです
世の中のすべての問題っていうのは
このエゴから生まれるんです
それさえ捨てれば一切問題はすべて解決しますけどね
そこで そういう話は今説明しましたからね
今日はその話はしません
で そのエゴがない方がいいんだけど
人間にはそれエゴの影響もありますけど
負けたくはないんですね
負けたく負けず嫌いっていうのは
それ負けず嫌いは種類あるんです
一つは自分がエゴがあって
プライドがあって 俺は負けたくはないんだと
負けるのは嫌だと思って戦うと
それはもう仏教から見れば間違っているんです
エゴだから我だから 自我だから
エゴイストだから だからその人は負けたくないということは決して良くない
そこでエゴがなくても正しい負けず嫌いのやり方があるんです
というのは 負けてたまるかということなんですね
怠けて物事を無茶苦茶にして
真剣に問題にぶつからないで
で 自分が負けちゃったと
それは恥ずかしいんだと
エゴとは関係ないんです
何か仕事を頼ま頼まれたところで
もういい加減で 中途半端で
もう半分寝ながらいい加減にやったと
それで結果は良くないでしょう
負けてしまう その負け方は良くない
ですから 私はこの負けず嫌いということ
負けたくはないということをいい方向へ持っていって使ってくださいと言いたいんです
それはエゴと関係なく
私はこういう仕事をしなくちゃいけない
今日は私が料理を作らなくちゃいけない
それは自分に対する自分のチャレンジなんですね
それをしっかりと真剣にやって
立派にできるようにすると
みんなに美味しく食べられるように
一つ文句言えないように作って作りますと
それもある意味で負けず嫌いの性格なんですけど
それ別に誰かに褒めてほしいとか
私は偉いんだとか 誰かに言われてもらうではなくて
この仕事自体中途半端ではやってこの怠けて
それ不放逸ということの不放逸ということなんですけど
そういうふうにはしたくないんだと
いわゆるやることは精一杯しっかりやりたいんだと
負けたくはないんだと
ということを覚えておいてください
人は負ける必要はないんです
誰にも 自分やることはちゃんと精一杯やればいいんです
それで怒る人が確実に負ける
怒ったということは負けたということなんです
ほんのわずかでも 自分がどんなものについてでも怒ったならば
もう自分の負けなんです
怒るべきことはいっぱい出ているのに怒らない場合は
その人はそれを勝っているんです
試してみてください 普通の人生の中で怒る瞬間で怒らないでいてみてください
その状況は 自分が必ず自分の希望通りに
もう自白するんです 負けたらすぐそこでも負けたらじゃなくて
怒ったらすぐそこでも負けるんです
ですから 怒りっていうのはもう負けたという同じことなんです
負けると悔しいでしょうし
悲しいでしょうし 楽しくないんです
何かやって成功すると
人生っていうのは楽しいんです
だからこの我々は日々成功
1時間1時間単位で あるいは 1分1分単位で
でも成功することを考えなくちゃいけない
この 1 分で自分やらなくちゃいけないことを成功するんだと 1
分ぐらいでいいんです
もうもう10年後で何か成功するぞと思って計画立てて
まあそこまで行っちゃうというと苦しいんだけど
そうじゃなくて  1分1分単位で今やることは成功するんだと
この 1 分間でやることは精一杯やって成功するんだという
その成功と一緒に喜びを感じる
幸福感を感じる そこで怒った瞬間で
それは失敗 で ほんのわずかに怒る
例えば文章を書いていて
ちょっと間違いがあったら
すぐわずかにその瞬間怒るんです
あ 嫌だとか なんとかとか言って
たまにいろんな機械とかね
うまく動かないとか それ叩いたりとかね
いろいろことやって その瞬間怒ってるんです
なんでこれ動かないんですかとかね
叩いたり蹴ったりする時で怒ってるでしょ
負けてるんです その時
ですから この瞬間でも怒ったら
それは自分の人生負けたことということは不幸を味わっていること
ですから 怒らない瞬間で
自分がその状況に打ち勝ったと
と覚えておいてください
だから勝利者になる 負け犬にならないこと
勝利者になるためには怒らないこと
怒る人は負け犬 それについでに言いたいんだけど
世の中で あの なんか怒ることを立派にかっこいいと思っているのはとんでもないアホな人々いるんですよ
すっごい悪い言葉喋って
人を殴ったり蹴ったり
なんか暴力振るったりして
それで自分の立場 そこでこの家庭の中でも
たまにこの奥さんをいじめたり殴ったりとかね
そこで自分がえらい亭主関白だとか思ったりとかね
あれは病気なんです 奥さんたちもいますよ
まあ旦那に怒るは まあ全部とにかく支配して抑えて潰しちゃいたいぐらいで
もうそれは自分がしっかりやってるとはえらい勘違いしてるんです
みんな病気なんです この自分の奥さんをね
けなしたり まあ怒ったり
もう叱ったり ああだこうだとか
最近テレビでちょっとした番組見たんだけど
若い人がなんか 随分病気だなと思ったんだけど
それは病気なんです 怒り福人は怒ることは決してかっこいいわけじゃないんです
ああいう人々はなんか随分俺自分の中がものすごい空っぽで何もない
ただ私の言葉で言えば
単なる動く肉の塊 だから何が欲しいんですよ
私という風に言うために
それで怒ったり 人を殴ったり
暴力を振るったり 偉そうなことをしたりするんです
それ恥ずかしくて それ精神的な病気なんです
それで もともとも 例えば男性の場合はね
そういう病気で中身がなくて
何にもなくて それで結婚したりする
それで偉そうに自分が私は夫だ旦那だっていう感じで命令したりして
それでずっと死ぬまで不幸ばっかり
すごい不幸なんです ですから
この怒ることは決してかっこいいわけじゃないんです
あれはものすごいかっこ悪いんです
すごい弱いんです ですから
怒る人は精神的にも肉体的にも徹底的に弱い
で 怒らないことによって
精神的に肉体的にすごい力強い人間になります
だから暴力を振る人はものすごく弱いんです
勇気が全くないんです
だから暴力を振って何か抑えてやろうと思っているだけ
人間の社会でいろんな武器を作って作って力強くなろうなろうと思うのは
その分弱いんだからなんです
その分情けないんだからなんです
だからまあ社会的な言葉で言うならば
平和を語る人はものすごい強者であって
いやもう負けてはたまりませんと戦ってやるぞという人が典型的な弱者なんです
平和には勇気を必要し
戦争にはその反対に 何と言いますか
弱さですね ですから 我々はそれを理解して
怒ることはかっこいいものじゃないんだと
怒った瞬間にものすごい恥ずかしくなってください
怒ったら次に何言うとものすごい恥ずかしくなってください
ああ弱いんだと 精神的にも弱いんだと
肉体的にも自分が弱いんだと
うん 大体まあ そういうふうに一般的な
まあいろいろ方法はございます
で まあそれからもうちょっと難しいことをしゃべろうかなと
で このテーマの今まで喋ったのは一般的なところ
これからちょっと仏教の世界に触れて
今まで言ったことも仏教の考え方なんですけど
まあ仏教の世界に入って
次にあの ちょっと休みます？じゃあ五分休憩して仏教の世界に入りましょうか
じゃああの 始まります
で 今までの話は略すると
まあ最後のことを略すると
怒って損するなと 笑って得しましょうということで覚えておいてください
怒ったら損するんだと
笑ったら得するんだと
あるいはもう一つは 怒る人はまあ弱いものやと
笑う人はすごい強いものだと
ですから強者が笑う 弱者が怒ると
まあそれぐらいのことで
いくらか頭で覚えておく必要はあります
それから私はなんかすごいなんか人を貶すような感じで喋ったかもしれません
それは人を貶すじゃなくて
自分の怒りをとことん貶してやってください
そうでないと怒るんです
だから今日の私は喋る時でも
なんかすごいもうなんか人をもうなんのことなく
まあ貶して まあゴミ扱いして喋ったような感じで喋ったんだけど
それはわざとそういうふうに喋ったんです
そういうふうにこの怒りのことを思ってください
きったないゴミだと 嘘の塊だと
恥ずかしがってください
怒りに対して で 次に出てくる問題っていうのは
この何があっても怒らないというと
人が悪いことをすると
どうしても怒らなくちゃいけないことをすると
あまりにも人がね あまりにも悪いことをすればどうすればいいんですかと
その人はその自分の世界でいろんな悪いことをしているならば
それは別に人のことやって人をやっていることだから怒る必要はまずない
それはニコニコと笑ってね
そこはおかしいとこ見つかって
笑いながら説明して教えてあげればいいんです
たまに自分にいろんなことをするとなんか問題でしょうね
自分に損をしたり 自分を貶したり
自分を馬鹿にしたり 自分が何も悪いことしてないのにと
その場合はどうすればいいんですかね
自分を差別しようとする
貶そうとする 落とし穴に入れようとする
あるでしょ そういうこと
その時もう怒らないでニコニコしてちゃとことんバカにされるんではないかと
と思うんですね その場合はですね
その時でも人は私をバカにしようとする
それで私は怒っちゃったらバカを認めたことになっちゃうんです
その時 だからその時でも怒ったら相手が勝ったことになるんです
相手があんたはもう散々批判する
あんたバカだ もうとんでもない人だ
無責任な人だとか怒ってくると
全部認めたことになるんです
認めて相手の方の勝ちになっちゃうんです
それで頭の中であなたはバカですよと言ったって
私はバカになるわけじゃないんだと
あんたは無責任な人だと言ったって
別に無責任になるわけじゃないということだから
人が勝手に何言ったってどうぞご勝手にという感じでいればいいんです
それで一応解決します
どうぞ自由にやってくださいと
自分が強いんだと 自分が水晶の玉のように
いろいろいろんな水がいろいろもうどんな染めている色水がついても吹いちゃえばいいんだと
つけませんだと これスポンジのようになっちゃったらもう負けなんですね
だから心が水晶の玉のように光り輝くような心にして
相手側からどんな色をつけてる水をつけたっても
まあ臭い ものすごい臭いものを出しちゃっても
水晶の玉だからもう吹けばそれできれいです
そういうふうに心を持っていけば
だいたい外から自分に出てくる攻撃に対処できるんです
それでもあんまりにも向こう側が人を攻撃しようすると教えてあげた方がいいんです
力強く それは怒りじゃないんです
怒り 怒ったら自分の負けですからね
たまにいるんですね 社会に迷惑をかけるは
他人に迷惑をかけるは
まあそういうのは無知の塊なんですね
その場合は その人にきつく
言った方が二度とそういうことをするなと
そういうことをしたら
こういう風に私も対応対応するんだと
で 少々きつくなっても構いません
だから仏教と それをお釈迦様の考え
ある教の内容から 僕はちょっと思い出していますけどもね
いつでも私は怒りません
怒りませんと言っても
なんかね 自分が小さくて
それは逃げる必要ないんですよ
堂々たる精神でいるんだから
怒らないだけで で その人に脅す時でも怒っていると自分の負けなんです
怒ってなく すごい知恵
知識を持って あんたもう同じことをまた二度とやっちゃうと
私もしっかりやるぞと言うと
相手はものすごく怖くなるんです
怒って言っちゃうと無知だから
ですから 自分に損をした人に
かえってそれに何かする場合は
知恵のある人が知識ある人にはきちんとその人にその分返してあげることができるんです
でまあわかりやすく言えば
例えばこの日本でもよく見られますけど
誰か殺されたんだと そこで被害者の人々はもうそこで相手のことを怒って怒って
で いろんなことを言ったり行動したりするんです
それでは正しい答えじゃないんですね
例えば 私の誰かを殺したところで
私は怒ってもあんた殺してあなたも殺してやるというと
殺しちゃったらどうなるかというと
自分が殺人になっちゃうんですね
それは返しじゃないんです
酷いことをする人には返してあげることは別にも
それもそんなに悪くないと私は思いますよ
ちょっとひどい目に遭わせてあげると
それでも理解してみろと
それは随分知恵で随分理解があった上でできることで
普通にはなかなかできないんですね
ですから そういうことを
例えば自分をいじめている人がいるんだと
自分がそれでも怒りませんし
その人が頭が悪くて人をいじめをしているんだとわかったら
この人本当にバカだから
なんかこうすればなんかちょっと面白いのではないかと
ちょっとその人をなんかそれは感じるより何かすることはできます
自分をやっていること
で それは私はわかりやすい例えで
方法は教えませんよ それは恐ろしいんだから
で これで覚えておいてください
あまりにも外側から自分に攻撃されたり
貶されたりするならば
自分が落ち着いているんだから
それはいいことにして
やりたい放題やっていると
相手に鏡を見せると 自分が怒るんじゃなくて
相手に鏡を見せるという法則で言い返しちゃうか
やり返しちゃうか それだけ
それしか言えません で
相手に鏡を見たら 相手は自分の顔を見てもう怖くなるんだから
日本で出てくる閻魔の話がありますね
閻魔ですかね 地獄にいる神様が
であれは一応仏教の世界で出来上がっているストーリーだから
閻魔さんが人が死んじゃったら審判するんですね
そこでその審判のやり方っていうのは
このヨーロッパ的にあんたは神を信じなかったんだから地獄はあなた神を信じたんだから天国だとかね
人の命ずいぶん自分勝手に判断するっていうことはね
そうはしません その代わりに鏡を見せると
その鏡で自分が何をやってきたんだっていうことは自分でわかりますから
本人がなるほどいいこと一つもやってないんだ
やっぱり自分が地獄だと
これ 閻魔さんのせいじゃ閻魔様がもう判断くださらなくても
はい わかります と 私はこっちに行きますと
そういうふうに本人で決めて
その罰を受けるようになるんです
そちらにもこの悪いことをする人に
この悪いことで言い返すんじゃなくて
自分の悪いことの結果は自分で受けるようにしてあげると
そういうことはもうちょっと覚えておいてください
鏡を見せるという法則を
ですから 言い返すんじゃなくて
やり返すんじゃなくて
どうしてもひどいんだったら
自分を責めてるんだったら
鏡を見せると それは一番ものすごいきついんです
本人にとっては 私をぶったならして殴り返しちゃったら
別に全然もうそれほど心に残らないんです
やられたっていうこと
でお釈迦様やることも
私たちも寺ではよくやることというのは
人をぶったりとかね 叱ったりはしない
悪いことしちゃうと どうしますかと
完全に無視するんです
それはすごい強烈です
何言おうが何しようが
もう知らんふり この社会から追い出そう
でも物理的に追い出すことはない
まあ一緒にご飯食べたくて
別にまあ別に人間だからね
ちゃんとそういうのは用意してあげるし
で 病気になったならば
それをもうちゃんとそれはもうやるんだけど
この一緒に生活する 一緒に一緒に生活
行動 活動している一人としてまあ扱わないで
な 無視 発言したっても
じゃあ次の人 あんた何なんですか？とか動かないと
あのショックというのはもう人間には耐えられないんです
こちらで叱ったことでもないし
何の罪も犯したことない
こちらで怒って叱った
なんであんたこういうことするんですかと
みんなこういうふうにするべきではないかと
こちらも罪に罪を犯しているんだから
だから論理はこういう人はこの道徳は守らない
みんなとみんなの決まりは守らない
調和は守らない 相手をいじめようとすることだけ
わがままで自分勝手で自分本位で
それだったらその人はどうぞ自由に自分本位でやってくださいと
そういうことにやらせてあげる
ですから 自分がやることの結果が自分で受ける
いわゆる社会で調和を守らない人がみんなから無視されて
とことんその苦しみを味わう
それは世の中の罰の中で一番力強い強烈な罰なんです
で 無視したことっていうのは
我々はもうたまにやりますけどね
あれはあまりにも無視してるんじゃないんだよ
人を言うことを聞いてくれないし
だから心の中でもういろいろ感情があるんです
あるある上で人のことを無視しようとする
それは無視にならない
心の中からもうその人はもう置いといて
ないようにして行動する
その分落ち着いて もう楽しくニコニコと行動すると
向こうにはすごいそれ
例えばたまにいるでしょ
夫婦はもう 1週間とか口をきかないとかね
苦しいんですね その時は
なぜ苦しいかというと
本当は喋りたいし 相手のこと気になって
もう何か怒ってるんだからね
その時もああだこうだとか
そこで無視されてる感じにならないんです
そこでお互いに勝手にしろと
そうじゃなくて もう本当に無視して
自分を無視したことによって損してはいけない
その人は自分に損を与えるんだから
自分がその人を無視することによって幸福になると
自分がニコニコと堂々と楽しく
わずかにでもその人と口をきかないことは寂しいとかね
やっぱり口をきいた方がいいとかね
思わないで もう堂々と独立して生活すると
向こう側はやっぱり自分がめげな
負け負け 負け 負け 負けられなくちゃいけないんだと決めちゃうんです
お釈迦様のこのチャンナというこの出家
再家の時 この運転手がいたんですね
運転手がいたんだけど
車はなかったんだけど
いわゆる馬の馬やら車やらね
馬車とかね そういう時はいつでもその人が運転してくれるんです
だからこのえらい社会でしたから
どんな人でももう馬車に乗って
じゃあ私は連れて行きますということはできません
そういう大臣クラスの人がいて
このおじ様だからね あっちこっち連れて行ったりする
そのチャナなんですけど
名前はね そのチャナさんもこのお釈迦様のこと
大変ありがたくてありがたくて
大事に大事に もう必死になって面倒を見ていたんです
そこで 夜 夜か昼かわかりません
出家した時も お釈迦様はその人と一緒に行ったんです
馬に乗って行ったんだけど
馬車ではなくて その時もやっぱり自分のいつでもそばにいて面倒を見てくれる人だから一緒にいたんです
仲がいいんです そこで出家して
彼に全部責任任せて こういうものは全部うちに
返してあげてくださいと
私は出家したことを父親に報告してくださいと言ったようなストーリーあるんです
それでその人は後で出家するんですね
他のグループと一緒に
アナンダ尊者やらみんなと一緒に出家するんです
出家したと知って見たところで
そちらにはお釈迦様の側に側近のお坊様たちが違う人々なんですね
今までずっと自分がまあ一緒にいたのに
いつでも釈迦さんが再建の時一緒にいたのに
出家したところ 自分が随分遠いところにいなくちゃいけない
側にいるのは他の方々なの
サーリプッタ尊者やらモクレン尊者やら大カッシャパマハカッシャパ尊者やら
そういう偉大なる阿羅漢たちがいろんな行動をしているし
お釈迦様はそういう人々にいろんなことを言ったり頼んだりはしている
お釈迦様もちゃんとこれやってください
あれやってくださいとは言わない
なんか寂しかっただろうと思いますけど
でも 仏教の出家の世界では
やっぱり聖なる世界だから道徳しかもう聞かないんですね
ただ どんな生まれか 金持ちかないか
そんなものはもう関係ないんだから
心は清らかかないかっていうことで判断する世界だから
だから清らかな悟った方々は側にいて
他の方々は修行中っていうことでもう近寄らない
で この人はすごいわがままになったんです
みんなに文句言い始めたんです
今更あなた方は何をと
今お釈迦様は有名になって
もう大変偉大なる人になっているところで
偉そうに側にいて ああだこうだとか
その方は小さい時から面倒見たのは誰ですかと
誰と一緒に出家したと思ってるんですかと
私だよと だから釈迦さんという個人の小さい時からの面倒見たのは私ではないかとと言って
他の人々はお坊様たちに対してはすごい態度でっかい
で 言うことを聞かない
だから出家したならばこういう生き方ですよ
こういうやり方です あんた方は何で今更私に説教するつもりですかと
いい加減にしなさいと
ただ ものすごい手強い人なんですね
だから修行するところか
教えてあげることも何もできない
それでお釈迦様も全然口きかない
というか もう何も言わない
お釈迦様のこと怖いんだから
もうお釈迦様に文句言うことはできなかっただけで
お釈迦様は亡くなる時
いろいろまあ話を聞いたりするんだから
これはどうしますか これはどうしますかとかね
お釈迦様自分が亡くなったら葬式はどうするべきかとか
そこもおっしゃって亡くなったんだから
そこでお釈迦様のやっぱり心の中にあるんですね
やっぱりお釈迦様ってすごいこの人々のことを思っているし
自分の面倒を見てくれた人々に対する感謝というか
その恩はものすごい徹底的に覚えているんだから
チャナさんのことも本当に心配なんですね
だからその人 自分のことをもう命と同じく大事に愛情を持っていることは知ってるんだけど
この態度だったらもうどうしようもないんだから
ですから お釈迦様亡くなるちょっと前にお坊さんたちにアナンダ尊者にチャナのことなんですけど
やっぱり心配ですね チャナのことなんですけど
あの人言うことは聞かないし
すごいわがままで 態度でっかくて
もうですから 私は亡くなったらみんな彼にはこのブラフマダンダということを決めなさいと
ブラフマっていうのは偉大なるという意味なんです
ダンダっていうのは罰
だからブラフマというのは聖なるという意味もありますよ
いわゆる聖者の罰 聖者をする罰
聖者は人をぶったりはしませんだから
聖なる罰を与えなさいと
そしたら聖なる聖なんか合わない言葉っていうのは
聖なると また罰というのはちょっと合わない言葉だから
聖なる罰って何ですか？ったら
で あなた方はサンガとして決めなさいと
サンガの人々 お坊さんたちは一人も誰ともしゃべらない
いわゆるいろんなお坊さんたちの集まりやら儀式やら儀礼やらいろんなものありますね
そういう正式的に報告するべきことやら
それ何一つも言わないこと
報告しないこと 彼が何言ってもそれは構いません
彼が何を報告したっても
それは構いませんだけど
こちら側は何もしないことと
何も喋らないことという風に言ったんですね
そこではい わかりましたと
それでそれみんなに知られる時間ではなかった
お釈迦様はその場でまたすぐ亡くなりましたから
それ言って またなんかなんかみんなに他のいろんなことを言って
それでも亡くなりました
そこでお釈迦様亡くなったっていうこと
大騒ぎなことだからね
それも終わって 葬式も終わって
ちょっと落ち着いたところでお坊さんたちと阿羅漢たちが集めて
お釈迦様の言葉全部もう決めなくちゃいけないし
で 集めて このじゃあチャンナの罰を決めましょうと
お坊さんたちの会議でチャンナさんに釈尊の命令もしたんだから
こういう罰を決めますと決めて
その罰を決める会議にも彼は呼ばなかったんです
普通だったら呼ぶんですけどね
言ってアナンダ尊者が報告するんです
決まりだから 言ってチャンナのところに
チャンナさんもアナンダ尊者も同じ一緒にいた人々だからね
その人も随分悲しがっていたでしょうと思いますけど
お釈迦様亡くなって あなたにはお釈迦様の決まりで
最後にこのあなたには罰を決めたんだと
どういう罰か ブラフマダンダですよ
聖なる罰ですよ あれどういうことかと聞いたら
こういう罰ですよと 我々は今日からあなた方
あなた方とは何も口を利かない
あなたは勝手に喋るのは自由ですよと
これから その罰の報告を受けた瞬間で
チャンナが意識を失って倒れたんだそうです
それはすごい強烈なんです
意識がなくなったんです
それだからといって甘えるっていうことは仏教でないんです
あ これきついんだから
ちょっと甘えてあげます
それはない それでも誰も話を口をきかないんだから
ものすごいショックを受けて一人になって一生懸命もうそれで瞑想始めたんです
始めてすぐもう悟りましたけどね
まあ悟ったら全ての罰っていうのは自動的に解除するんで
もう完全な人になったんだから
それでもやっぱり正式的にやっぱり道徳守りますから
自分がこのお釈迦様にもいろいろ失礼なことをしてお坊さんたちにそういう罰を受けましたと
それはこれからはちゃんと自分を戒めますので
どうかそれを何て言いますか
変えてくださいとお願いするんです
お願いしたところで また会議を集めて
チャンナがこういうふうに謝ることで
お坊さんたちは反対でなければ
その罰をこれから中止しますという結論を出して中止してあげるんです
ということだから この我々にとって
社会にとって あんまりにもひどいことをする人がいるならば
怒らないで頑張っていても
その人はずっと続けちゃうでしょうに
そうするとやりたい放題でしょうに
誰も怒りませんだから怖いものないと
それは良くないんです
怒ると怒られたからといって怖くなっていくらく抑えますからね
普通の法律ではそういうことでね
みんな怒るんだから みんな怖くて悪いことしないようにコントロールしてますけど
仏教は逆に怒りません
それでも怒りません だから自由をやりたい放題やっちゃうと一番きつい罰をする
その人をもう完全に無視しちゃう
じゃあ一人でやってみてくださいと
それは愛情で慈悲でやっていることであって
文句は言えない ですから
それはこの鏡を見せるというやり方で
自分で自分やったことをもう反省しなくちゃいけない状態になるんです
そういうことも覚えておいてください
単なるこの怒らないんだからといって
なんだかんだもうはいはいわかりましたとか
そういう弱気の性格ではないんです
ちゃんと何かあんまりもひどいことをする人にとっては
それなりのことをすればいいんです
あの大変有名な何でしたっけ
この余計なストーリーに随分時間なくなったんだけど
サーリプッタ尊者がいまして
このサーリプッタ尊者っていうのは怒らないことには有名なんですね
怒らないことで有名じゃなくて
阿羅漢たちは誰も怒りませんだけど
この謙虚であること お釈迦様は自分の右腕だとずっと言っていたのに
たまに言うんです ブッダたる私か
私か このサーリプッタ尊者か
どっちでしょうかと あなた方にはしっかり教えられるなって
それぐらい自分がこの偉大なる弟子のことを褒めていたんですね
その方が本当にもう素晴らしい知識があった人なんです
もう智慧っていうのはもう並外れなものでしたから
それなのに もう誰よりも謙虚的なんです
あんまりにも謙虚的で
ほとんど人々はわからないほど
どちらがこの偉大なるサーリプッタですかと
このアインシュタインのところじゃないんですよ
智慧のところというのは
随分ものすごい智慧があったんだから
それなのに ほとんど誰もわからないほど謙虚に
ですから 怒らないというよりは
その謙虚のために言っていることで
あるバラモンが 仏教のバラモンではなかったんだけど
このサーリプッタ尊者のことを聞いて
すごい性格はできている人だとかね
で なんだい ただのバラモン教は頭を剃ることはすごく貶しちゃうんですね
ですから ムンダカという
ハゲというような言葉なんですけどね
こんなハゲたハゲた連中って誰が気にするんですかと
でも悪口を言うんですね
で もう一人と バラモンの人を一人と行ったかでしょうと思いますけど
行って じゃあ本当にその人偉いかどうか確かめてみるんだ
どうせ人間だからね 何かもう見つかるんだと
欠点を 言って 後ろから行って
サーリプッタ尊者をすっごい勢いでぶん殴ったんです
サーリプッタ尊者はもう托鉢に出ていくんです
後ろから ものすごい力強くぶん殴ったんです
ぶん殴って もう人を何のことなくぶん殴られたら何かそこで反応を起こすでしょうに
後ろからぶん殴ったんだけど
サーリプッタ尊者がこうやって見ることさえなく
そのままずっとゆっくりと歩いているんです
この人が殴って待ってるんだけど
こうやって振り返ることもないんです
そこをもう後ろから行くんですよ
それで それでも見ようとはしない
で ぶん殴ったバラモン人が
これとんでもないことをしたんだと
殴られたということさえ気がつかないというか
気にならない で 怖くなりまして
随分恐怖感を感じて やっぱり自分がやったことはとんでもないこと
本当にこの人っていうのは素晴らしい人やと
思って怖くなって体が揺れ始めて汗が出て
早くさっさとそばに 前に行って
で 跪いて謝るんです 大変申し訳ないことをしましたんだけど
どうぞ私を許してください
ったら なんでしょうかね
サーリプッタ尊者が聞く
何をしたんですかと それぐらいそれはないんで
頭の中に だから妄想しない
おそらくあの時私を殴ったのはこの人ではないかと
そういう妄想がないんです
どういうことですかと聞いて
それでさらにその人怖くなったんですね
それもこの人の頭にないんだと
で 言われた 私はこういう悪いことをしましたと言われたところで
あ そう じゃあまあわかりました
もうそんなもう私はもう全然気にしてないんですからと
許してあげますと で 結局その人はそこで弟子になって
仏教徒になってしまったんだけどね
で そういうのは我々にはできないんです
とにかく それはもうサーリプッタ尊者は阿羅漢になったっていうことは
そういう実体っていうのは全くもう頭の中にもないんです
エゴっていうのは全くないんです
だから完全にサティでヴィパッサナーでいるんだから
そこでぶたれたら それは物質が物質に触れただけで
それで終わりと そこで痛みが生まれたら
それは心ですね 心は痛みを感じる
それだけで あ 痛みと それで私は痛いと
私はぶたれたという考え方は無意識のところにもない
だからああいう風な態度はできるんです
それでサーリプッタ尊者もう一つ性格がありまして
そういう それは怒らないというよりはとことん謙虚ということなの
だから我々も余計なプライドを捨ててとことん謙虚になれば怒らないと思いますけどね
あんな完全たる智慧の人
智慧の塊の人なのに ちょっと衣を着て
ところで ほんの一部 ちょっと垂らしていたということを垂らして
私は知らなかったんですね
ある沙弥がそれを見て
先生 そのちょっと衣をちょっとという風に見せたんですね
この衣着方決まってるんだから
私の着方ではない 私はいい加減ですけどね
で ほんのわずかなことなんですけど
そのそういうことでも教えてくれたということで
大変ありがとうございますとそこに座って
ありがとうございますと教えてくれて
その沙弥に感謝するんです
だから 自分がまあお釈迦様の右腕であって
仏教の世界で番目の方であって
沙弥っていうのはもう何のこともないことだから
それでもやっぱり自分には全く自我がないんですね
ですから そういうのは我々には完全に真似できませんだけど
覚えておいた方がいいんです
我々は 私は課長だから怒ったりする
なんだこの課長の状態とサーリプッタ尊者の状態と比べられますかね
私は旦那だからとかね
そんなことで怒るんだから
それは醜くて見ていられないほど醜いもんなんですよ
だからそこを覚えておくと
そういう風にこの謙虚っていうのは
この まあ仏教から言えば
我々にとっては 神よりも誰よりも
すべての生命の中で一番偉いのはお釈迦様なんです
じゃあ番目といえばサーリプッタ尊者なんで
一応順番つけるならば
お釈迦様順番つけてないんだけど
阿羅漢たちはみんな同じですけどね
そういう神も超えている
すべての存在も超えている偉大なる人さえ
ちょっと衣がちょっと下がってるんだと言っただけで
あれほど謙虚的に教えてくれて
本当にありがとうございますとと言ったんだから
我々どうですかね あんた何様ですかね
私にこんなこと言う そういう態度でしょ
我々は あるいは生意気言うなと
例えば大学でもね まあ年生とか年生に一年生がなんか言ったら
ひどい状態でしょ 学校でも高校でも
後輩の人がなんか言っちゃったらひどい状態のあれは醜いんです
私にとっては まあまあ
いきなり自分の国からこちらへ大学入ってみたら
ものすごい醜い姿なんですね
あの後輩たちを奴隷扱いして
もう何も言うこと権利はない
そこである意味ではざまあみろという感じもあります
うちでわがままでいたい放題
親いじめるは父親と喧嘩するはもう
じゃあ学校に行ってみたらどうですかと
最低の状態 でもけなされるは殴られるは
バカにされるは掃除させるは
もう全部ふんどしまで洗わせるんだから先輩たちに
でもそれ言われると別においといて
このもし後輩の人が一言葉でも間違ってることをちょっとでも言っちゃったら
ものすごく怒られるんですね
生意気言うなと それでみんな苦しみ味わってるでしょうに
いろんなところに入って
いろんな修行にいろんなところに入ったら
まあ入っただけの人々をいじめること
けなすこと だから醜い
あんな人間じゃないんですね
偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者さえ
沙弥に大したことじゃなく
あれぐらい言われたのに
偉大なる人だからちゃんとよく教えてくれました
ありがとうございますと
ですから 偉大なる人 本当にライオンみたいなしっかりしている人は
もう相手に生意気言うなと言わないんです
自分の何かを教えてくれたら
それは分かりましたと
自分が間違っている小さな子供でも言ったら
それちゃんと子供を褒めて褒めてあげる
そういうことはすごい素晴らしい仏教で言ったら道徳なんですね
だから 生徒が先生の間違い
こういうことを間違っているから
先生 私の立場はどうですかとか
メンツはどうですかとか
あれはもう立場ないんで
初めからメンツとかなんとか言葉使うと初めからもないんで
そういう人々にはもう空っぽなんですね
だから生徒にあ これ違いますよと言われたら
自分本当にそうですねとかね
その生徒を褒めてあげる
あんたよく知ってるんでしょ？しっかりしてるもんですねとか
生意気というんじゃなくて
ですから 世の中の立派な人っていうのは
人に自分の過ちとかなんとか教えてくれたら,それはどんな人であろうともありがたくよくわかりましたと
と そういう性格 そういうのは怒らない人々の道徳世界
これは聖なる世界 我々にも真似事はできます
そのまま実行はできませんですけどね
真似事ぐらいはできますよ
人に何か怒られた 何か言われたっても
まあ忘れちゃうと 忘れなくても忘れたふりでもする
そうすると我々の心は立派な心になります
だからこの前も言ったんだけど
大事なものは全部忘れて
人悪いことだけ覚えてるんだからね
心っていうのは 私は時間喋ったっても全部忘れて
何か間違ったことやら
何かもう気になることやら
気に障ること言ったらそれだけ覚えて
で 一生怒る怒りで苦しんでいるということは結構ありますからね
だから不幸になるようにできているんですからね
だから人は私たちとのことを年褒めてもらっても
たった一回叱ったらそれで終わり
だからそれバカバカらしいでしょ
心の働きっていうのは
だから怒ることはバカっていうのはそういうわけでも言えるし
そういうことで この我々もサーリプッタ尊者の生き方は
まあ真似はまあいわゆるそのまま実行できません
それはまあしょうがない
そんなに立派に尊くなるわけじゃないんだからね
ですから真似事でも覚えておいて
謙虚でなることは尊い人だと
謙虚になることは聖なる生き方だと
たとえ子供にでも何か言われたら
それはその通りであるならば
それは先生のようにその人のことをありがたく思うこと
それは私は立派にできているという意味だと
ただ 自分がよくできたものやと嘘を何で言うんですかね
本当にできた人だったらそんなもんなんです
いつでも相手の批判を聞く耳を持っている
例えば専門家がやった仕事にしたっても
素人に何か見たら あ これはどうかなと言えるところいっぱいあるでしょうね
そこでもしプロの人にだけ言ったら
まあまた二度とも口きかないんですね
あんた何様ですかと 私はプロでしょうと
そう言うと その人はプロじゃないんです
人が何か言ったら それはちゃんと聞いて
アインシュタインのストーリーあるんですね
あの 何て言いますか 誰も知らないところに大学からね
その大学の研究所の人しか知らないんだったそうですね
アインシュタイン住んでいた場所は
そこにこの学校の先生が
この自分の女の子があまり算数ですか
もううまくいかなくて
なんであんたそれちゃんと勉強して
あなたの隣に住んでるのはもう算数できる人でしょうに
なんかちょっと言ったみたい
でも子供は知らない これ誰のことを言っているかと
これは なるほど 自分の宿題は隣の家のおじいちゃんに聞いてもらえば教えてもらえばいいと平気で言って
ピンポン鳴らしちゃったら
ドア開けたらちっちゃな女の子だから
まあどうぞと おじいちゃん
先生 学校の先生はおじいちゃん算数は上手だと言ったんですよと
だからこれは教えてちょうだいと言っても
もう誰にも電話番号も言ってない
住所も言ってない それぐらいもう大事な人だから
もう大変忙しいし 時間はないし
で コインの採算みたいな人でしたからね
アメリカの 何のことなく
そのアインシュタインさんが彼女に全部教えてあげると
そこであまりも算数が上手になって
先生はあんた最近よく先生言ったって
あのおじいちゃんに聞いてもらって
それは先生も驚いちゃったって
大変なことになったんだと
言って それは母親に言っても
こういう大変なことになったと
私はもう別にそういう意味で言ったわけじゃなくて
ただ隣はアインシュタイン住んでることを自分が知ってるっていうことだけ言いたかっただけなんですよ
そしたらお母さんも行ってもう自分の過ちで大変迷惑をかけたんだっていうことを謝りに行ったんですね
そしたらアインシュタイン
いい 何のこともないんです
私は何も教えて 私はいろんなことを教えてもらったんだと
教えてもらったのは私の方だよと
と言われたそうで そこにやっぱり偉大なる人の性格見えるでしょ？人ができていると
これ相対論を発見した人なのに
この小学生の子供 子供
子供では比べられないでしょう
いろんなことを教えてもらったんだと
だから本当に僕はアインシュタイン嘘を言っていると思ってないし
人ができているんだから
子供からもいろんなことを勉強できるんです
人ができているのと あんた何だ
小学生ではない こっち来るなとかね
でっかい態度をとる ですから
この仏教の礼から言うと
そういう風にこの聖なる生き方で我々に怒りを収めることはできます
立派な人になろうではないか
尊い人になってみろではないか
偉大なる性格を作ってみようではないか
できなくても真似事でもしてみれば立派になるんだからね
ということを覚えておいてください
それで学者の方々は まあこれからちょっと専門の世界に入りますけど
学者の方々はお釈迦様を仏教研究経典研究して
この一番この古いと最高層に入れているテキストがございまして
いわゆる疑いなく仏説だと
わずかな疑いもなく仏説だと
いわゆるお釈迦様が生きていた時も
そのお経をみんな覚えていたんだから
お釈迦様もそれに引用しているんだから
私は昔はこういうことを言ったんではないかと
ですからもう完全に疑いなく仏説だと言っているところがありまして
まあそのテキストはパーリ語でスッタニパータというんです
それは中村先生が訳してますね
ブッダの言葉という本なんですけど
あの中村先生の訳は随分簡単に分かりやすいんだけど
それはあの先生は偉大なる先生だから分かりやすく書いているだけであって
内容は決して簡単ではないんです
たまにみんな私はブッダの言葉をよく読みましたとか偉そうなことを言うんだけどね
僕は困ったなと思いますよ
それは中村先生のあのすごい知恵で
日本語の能力っていうのはもう並のものじゃないし
あれ訳できないんですよ
訳してますけど どうぞ読んでみてください
そちらの 1番目 偈一 読んでみてください
それは怒りに関する偈なんです
えーと 覚えてるはずなんですけど
一行目はよーうっぱティタンディネーティコーダン
よーうっぱティタンディネーティコーダンウィサタンスアッパウィサンワオーサデーヒソービッくジャハティオーラパランウラゴージンナミーワタチャンプラーナ
それを暗記しなくちゃいけないものなんですけど
でも内容は随分大変難しいんですけどね
でも中村先生の訳をお読みになると
簡単に我々に分かりやすい訳をしているんです
日本語で言えばこういう意味だそうです
蛇の毒が身体の隅々に広がるのを薬で制するように
怒りが起こったのを 制する修行者が修行者がこの世とあの世とを共に去ると
私が書いて私に読めない
蛇の脱皮して古い皮を捨て去るようなものであると
で 私が訳します よ 誰かがうっぱティタン
生まれた コーダン 怒りをヴィネーティ
制する コントロールする
誰かが怒りが生まれたら
それをすぐコントロールする
なくす ですから 私は冗談を言ったんじゃないんです
講演の初めに 怒ったら怒らないでください
それだけですよ だからお釈迦様も同じく怒らないことだ
それだけ こちら言ってるのはそういうこと
怒りが生まれたらそれはコントロールする
どのように ヴィサタン サッパウィサンワ オーサデーヒ
ヴィサタンっていうのは広げた
サッパウィサンっていうのはヘビの毒
ヘビの毒っていうのは皆様あまり実感ないかもしれませんだけど
恐ろしいもんです 猛毒です
秒十分です 人を死ぬためには
体に入って ヘビの毒 サッパというのはヘビ
ウィサンというのは毒
だから猛毒ですね 広げた猛毒をオーサデーヒ
薬で オーサっていうのは薬
薬で毒を 猛毒をなくすように
だからどうしますか？体に怒りが生まれた
それはヘビの猛毒のように感じて
すぐ薬で消しちゃう その薬っていうのはまあそこで難しくなりますから
まあそれは仏教の修行の世界なんですね
薬って何ですか？怒りをなくす
それは修行の世界になりますけど
そこでそれで意味が 三行目にソービックー
そのビクが その修行者がジャハディ オーラパラン
ジャハディっていうのは捨て去る
オーラっていうのはこちら側
彼岸 パランっていうのは他岸ですか
なんとかわからない こちら側と向こう側
この世とあの世 いわゆる輪廻
いわゆる存在 生きて生きて生き続けている世界
いわゆるすべてを超越すると
解脱するという意味なんです
どのように ウラゴー ジンナミワ タチャン プラーナ
ウラゴーっていうのはヘビ
ヘビはタチャンというのはヘビの皮を
プラーナというのは古くなった
ヘビの皮が古くなったらどうしますか？脱皮しますね
そのように ジンナンというのはまた
また古くなったって意味なんですけど
あ チンナミはジンナ わかりました
ちょっと間違った これジンナと言っても
もしかするとチンヌ 捨てるという意味なんですね
これ古いパーリ語だから
ちょっとしたことで間違うんです
だからヘビが古い皮を脱皮するように怒りを脱皮してくださいと
だからものすごい仏教は怒りに対してはすごいもう
これ毒なんです 怒り自体ずいぶん毒
毒ということを言ってるんです
現代の皆様にも信じること
信じることはできるでしょう
なんかこの誰かお医者さんが本書いてあったでしょうね
怒ったり欲張ったりすると
体から悪いホルモンが出たりして体壊したりするんだ
ああだこうだとかね そういうどうでもいい人が言ったらみんな信じますからね
で お釈迦様が言っちゃうと信じませんだからね
だから怒るべきところなんですけど
私も怒ってはいけませんだから怒ります
[笑い]偉大なる聖者が真理を体験した人が言うと
それを馬鹿にしようとする
誰かがもうどうでもいい人が言っちゃうと
すごいことを言ってる
あんた知ってますか？あなたあの本読んだんですかと
僕は読んで驚いた本がほとんどないんだから
お釈迦様の経典は読んで未だに驚きますけどね
とにかくそこで言いたがっているのは
怒りに対してこの一番最高な
一番古いと言っている経典の第一行は怒りに対して書いているんです
猛毒でいてくださいということで
死ぬんだと そこでもう一つ教本を書きます
それはただ綺麗な芸本です
[ページをめくる音]それはこの法句経
真理のじゃなくて 何て言ったっけ？真理のことで
もう一つありますね え
真理の言葉という中村元先生の訳してますけどね
そちらのあの二百二十二ダンマパダの
意味はそちらにあります
中村先生のあの真理の言葉というテキストの二百二十二番見れば見つかるんです Yo
ve uppatitan kodhan Yo
誰かが veっていうのは
もしかするともう確かにとかね uppatitan
kodhan 生まれたkodhan怒りをratan bhantan va dhare ratan
っていうのは車 bhantan
っていうのは壊れた 壊れた車のように思うならば
するならば 怒りが生まれたところで
その その怒りを壊れた車のようにするならばとあとで説明します tam
aham sarathin brūmi
そのtan その人がsarathin
本当の車の運転手として
いわゆる車のプロとしてだとaham私が言いますと rasmigghah
itaro jana rasmigghah
っていうのは何でしたっけ
あの昔の車っていうのは馬車だから
この馬つけて手であれ
なんて言います 掴む あの
たつな で itaro jana
他の人々の素性のたすなを持ってるんだと
この人 そうするとちょっと意味がわからないかもしれませんだけど
ちょっと難しいんですけど
そこでこのこういうこと
車が壊れちゃったらもう動かないんですね
で 車は人に例えてみましょう
で 自分の心に怒りが生まれたと
生まれた怒りがすぐその場で消しちゃう
怒って何か行動しようとしない
怒った瞬間で怒りを消してもらう
消してもらったならば
その人をこそリーダーであって勝った人やと
私はずっと言ったのはそういう意味なんです
怒ったら負けだと 怒らない人は勝利者だと言ったんですね
そういうことなんです sarathin
っていうのは この運転手っていうのは現代意味しますけど
パーリ語では leader 勝利者という意味も持ってるんです
英雄という意味も持ってるんです
だから 本当の英雄 本当のリーダーが怒りを消した人であると
怒って私は偉いぞという人ではないんです
あなた方は何だという人はリーダーじゃないんです
そこでaham brūmi
お釈迦様は強調するんです
私が言いますと 私の意見
ブッダの言葉 ですから
怒らない人こそ勝利者であることはブッダが確実に言ってるんです
そこでitaro jana
他の人々は 他の人々のrasmigghah
たすなを使っているのはその人なんです
だから怒らない人が他の人々のたすなを掴まってるんです
ということです そのことは意味が分かりますね
怒らない人言う通りに怒っている人々は行動しなくちゃいけないんです
リーダーになるのはいつでも怒らない人なんで
この政治の世界にしたっても
お互いにやり合ったり貶し合ったり
いろいろあるでしょうに
そこで残って大臣になることやら総理になることやらなる人々はかなりこの何言おうとも落ち着いて落ち着いてニコニコと
でしょうに だからもう大臣やら総理大臣やら
そういう立場になるんです
ちょっとしたことで怒って喧嘩しちゃうと
もう議員の立場もなくなってしまっちゃうんです
ですから リーダーになる人っていうのは
本物のリーダーは決して怒りません
怒らない人はみんなの手綱を持ってるんです
捕まってるんです そこでまたたくさんありますけど
もう一つ一行 これ全部書かない
もうあまりたくさんありすぎて一行書きます
それはお釈迦様の言葉ですから
覚えていると何かいいことがあります
それもあの ある偈のあの一行だけ
コーダンジャヘイ 怒りを捨てろ
ヴィッパジャヘイ また捨てる
マーナンコーマン エゴ
つなげているんで その二つを
エゴを持ってるんだから怒るんです
ですから 怒りと一緒にエゴを捨てろと
次はまたまたありますけど
その同じ偈文のつながりがありますけど
それだけでも覚えておいてください
またいろいろ思い出すならば
この壊れた鐘のようになると
鐘がちょっと触ったらどうですか？すごい音するでしょ
我々は鐘のようにちょっと空気が触れただけで怒るんですね
あまり大胆なことなくても
ちょっと人がさっさと自分の前に歩いただけで怒るんですね
なんで？なんでそんな態度ですか？とか
もう随分付き合い付き合いにくいんですよ
でも前通るならば まあペコペコペコペコいろいろして
もうまあそうするのは別に悪くはないんだけど
もしちょっとでも何か間違いあったら
まあ例えば挨拶するともう体がちゃんと曲がってないんだと言ったりとか
人間にはそういう風に怒るんですね
だから鐘みたいんですよ
ちょっと触っただけでもすごい音するんです
だから自分の心っていうのは
ヒビ一つ入った鐘にしてなさいと
叩いても音しないんです
ですから そこからどんな攻撃を受けても
こちらは怒りの音は出さないと
それもエゴを捨てることと同じなんですね
また あの このものすごい怒りというのは猛毒だとおっしゃっているところ
いくつかまたあります
それでこの前の講義も言ったこの有名なストーリーがありましたし
それはあの あるお坊さんが女の人と随分仲がいいんです
あのお坊さん 女の人って尼さんたちなんですね
よく尼さんたちと一緒に話したり
仲良くしている そこでお坊さん出家したら
やっぱり男性は男性で
女性は女性で別々に行動しなくちゃいけない
特にあまり仲良く話したり
付き合ったりとか 友達作ったりはあまり認めてないんです
独立するために出家するんだから
それだったら男は男で
女は女で独立して行動しなくちゃいけない
この人をあまりにも仲良くしているんだから
まあそれはやっぱり批判されるんですね
批判されると怒る それで女の尼さんたちも
この人のことを誰かお坊さんに批判すると
尼さんたちも怒る あんないい人
なんであんた方はいろんなことを言うんですかと
ところであの尼さんたちのいろいろ悪いところ
悪いところについて他のお坊さんに聞いたら
またこのお坊さんが怒る
どうしようもない人なんです
そこでお釈迦様に報告したところ
お釈迦様はさんざん叱るんですね
まあ叱ると言ったっても
とことんきつく言うんです
それはもう 言ったところで
まあその人のことを置いといて
お釈迦様は昔話を言うんです
昔 ちょっと前 昔なんですけど
このその町で どこでしたっけ？サーワッティなんでしたけど
[咳]ある金持ちの女性の方がいたんだと
彼女の家でもう一人召使いの人がいたんですね
そこで彼女がこの召使いではなくて
そのご婦人の方が随分素晴らしい人ができていて
怒らない忍耐のある素晴らしい人だと
ものすごい有名なんです
だから 誰が見たって僅かに怒って
もうキャーキャーというのは聞こえない
そこでこの召使いの人の名前はカーリという名前なんですけど
あの その人が自分の主人と言うんで
その女性の場合も まあ主人が大変このできた人だと
怒らない人だと 世の中で随分人気があるんだと
マスコミでは随分人気あるんだと
で 本当かなと 本当にその人
落ち着いている人ですかと
もしかすると私はしっかりと仕事をしているんだから
彼女に怒る 何て言いますか
場面がないかもしれませんと
これ試してみようと このご婦人の方が本当に落ち着いている人かないか試してみようと思って
ある日わざと朝寝坊する
これ ずーっと何何 10年も一緒にいた人なんです
何10年も一度も間違いをしたことがないんです
この召使いの方が それで朝寝坊した
それで普通あの人を起きると
彼女が全部仕事して終わってるんですね
朝の食事の用意までなんだかんだで
自分が起きたところで
この召使いの人はまだ寝ている
仕事何もしてないんだから
それで言って なんであんたまだ寝ているんですかと
ちょっと言ったんですね
言ったら この召使いの人は目を見たんですね
目を見たらやっぱり怒っているとわかったんです
だから なんで寝ているんだい？いえ
別に何でもないんですよと言って起きたんです
別に何にもないんですよと
で 怒るように だからもうやっぱり怒ったことはわかったんですね
なるほど この人は別に落ち着いている人じゃないんだと
怒りがあるんだと ただ表れる場がなかっただけだと
そこでじゃあ次の日も確かめますと
次の日も朝寝坊したんです
したら このきつい言葉で
このちゃんと経典にこのきつい言葉で書いているんです
そういう言葉でも 何？何やってるんです？ああだこうだ怒ったんですね
なんで寝ているんです
いえ 別に何でもないんですよと
また 2番目の 2日目の日はもう怒っても叱った言葉で
彼女はじゃあ 3日目にも確かめてみると
3日も朝寝坊したんです
そこでもう彼女はもう叱るところじゃない
ドアにつける棒がありますから
鍵みたいな あれ？なんて言いますか
かん？かんぬき？そういうドア
止まる かなり大きいんです
で それ持ってきてぶん殴ったんです
小さいものじゃないので
結構重いんです 外からも開けられないように
このかなり大きくてつけちゃうんです
内側から それ持ってきてぶん殴ったんです
で ぶん殴っちゃったら頭が割れちゃって
体じゅう血だらけで で
彼女は何のことも言わないで外へ出たんです
外へ行って みんなの前であなた方は偉そうに随分落ち着いているんだとか言ってる私の主人のやったことを見てくださいと
私はちょっと朝寝坊しただけですよと
それにこんなもんですよと言ったら
みんなそれっきりで 他の出来事であのサーワッという町の全部
やっぱりあの人っていうのはとんでもない
ものすごい怒る もう奴隷をいじめる
召使いをいじめる もう気持ち悪い女の人だと
すぐあの名誉は 1日で消えてしまったと
そのストーリーを言って
お釈迦様何を言いたいんですか？じゃあやっぱり
怒らない原因がない時は誰でも落ち着いて立派な格好つけてるんですよ
それは本物じゃないと
例えばお寺に入って  2
3週間修行に入ったと
それはやっぱり心が良くなったとか
良くなったかないか社会に戻ってみろと
そういうのは本物じゃないんですね
だからみんな自分のことを褒めていると
怒りも私はあまり怒りませんよと偉そうなこと言うなと
みんなに貶されている時でもニコニコとしているならば
その人には怒りがないということなんですね
ですから 条件揃えば怒るんですよ
怒る条件が揃っていないと怒らないのは結構ありがたいことでもなんでもないんです
だから本当に怒りがないということは
怒るべき条件で怒らないことなんです
これ簡単なことなんですけど
そこで怒り 怒りを治めるためにお釈迦様がおっしゃっている例えいろいろあるんです
このように心を作ってくださいと
人々がいろんな方法に我々には喋る
それをお釈迦様は五つに分けてます
あの一つはこの 何といいますか
カーレーナ アカーレーナという言葉で
ちゃんとこの喋るべき時
あるいは喋ってはいけない時
喋る それ一つ 人が喋る時は喋るべき時喋る場合もあるし
喋ってはいけない時喋る場合もあります
番目は ブーテーナワブーテーナ
あるいは本当のことを言う場合もあるし
全く根拠のないものを言う場合もあります
これ叱る場合なんですね
叱る場合は叱るべき時叱る時もあるし
叱ってはいけない時叱ることもあります
それから根拠はあって叱る時もあるし
根拠はないのにも関わらず叱る時もあります
それから 優しい言葉で言う時もあるし
きつい言葉で言う時もありますと
それから 本当に意味のある言葉で
役に立つ言葉で叱ったりする時もあるし
どうでもいい言葉でも
ただ叱るだけの時もありますと
それから自分に対して慈しみを持って自分を叱る時もあるし
単なる自分に怒って人が何か言う時もありますと
ですから 人の言葉っていうのはそういうふうに五つに分けられる
そのどんな時でも心は落ち着いていますよと頑張ってくださいと
人は根拠あって喋っても
根拠がなくて喋っても落ち着いていますよと
偉大なる心持ちましょうと
人が私に対して慈しみの気持ちで喋っても
私に対して怒って喋っても
嫉妬して喋っても 心は広く持ちましょうと
どのように持ちますかというと
こういうこと 例えば人が小さなくわを持ってきて
地球に対して腹が立って
この地球めだと腹が立って
くわで地球はもうあっちこっちいじるんだと
いじって この地球は台無しにするんだと
破壊してやるぞと言って地球をいじめる
そこで地球はそれでいじめられますか？破壊しますか？くわ
くわでもって穴掘ったんだからといって
ですから そのように私は地球のような心を作りますと
人々からちょっとくわみたいなものでちょっと穴開けたんだからと
もう何も動けませんと
私は地球のような心を持ちますと
次の例えは ある人はいろんな絵の具を持ってくると
いろいろ色の絵の具を持ってくる
持ってきて 私はこの空でいろんな絵を描いて
いろんな絵でいろんな色で色で染めてしまうと
好きな放題いろんな絵を描きますよと
空に 絵の具は持っている
絵の具を持っていて いろいろ空の上で絵を描いたっても描けますかね
ただ本人の手が汚れるだけ
ですから 人々からどんな言葉言われても
私は空のような心でいますと
絵を描けない その絵っていうのは怒りなんですね
人が優しい言葉喋っても
きつい言葉言っても 五つの言葉言われても落ち着いているぞと
もう一つ この まあこれインドの例えなんですけど
この あの 昔あの懐中電灯なかったんだからね
あの 何か葉っぱとかなんか持ってきて
それを結んで そこに火をつけて持ってくんですね
あれなんていうその場合は
松明 人が小さな松明を持ってきて
ガンジス河に行って そのガンジス河の水を全部温めてやると
なくしてやると思って
自分の松明をガンジス河につけちゃうと
これはどうですかと そうするとどうなるんですかね
ガンジス河は水が沸騰して温まってなくなりますかね
ただ松明を消すだけだから
ですから 私は人々から何言われても
ガンジス河の これはインド人はガンジス河を知ってますからね
すごい大きい川なんですね
日本ではそんなに大きい川がないんだからね
ですから このガンジス河のような心を持ちますと
それは他人から言われる時はそういうふうに落ち着いていますということなんです
うーん次の例えは言ってもちょっとわからないかも
まあ次の例えを指しますけど最後の例えはまた一回目の講義でも言いました
で最後の例えはこの泥棒たちが来て泥棒じゃなくてこの悪い人々が来て自分を捕まって逆立ちにしてノコギリに切ってもわずかでも怒らないんだとと決めてくださいと
そういうふうに怒りを治めてほしかったんですね
わずかでも怒ってほしくなかったんだお釈迦様は
なぜならばそれは人間についてはずいぶん猛毒だから
ですからわずかでも怒る場合はこの最後の例えで覚えておいてください
お釈迦様最後にこう言うんです
もしノコギリに逆立ちにして自分をノコギリに切るときでもわずかでも気持ち悪くなったら怒ったらまあ私の弟子じゃないんだと
私の言うこと聞く人じゃないんだと
それぐらいお釈迦様は厳しく怒りというものは人々がコントロールしてほしかったんです
以上です どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]